[David Landsman, PhD]
When I was a child,
I spent a lot of time thinking on my own.
There was a huge oak tree in
our backyard and I used to sit
and the wind always blew. The
thing was moving all the time.
And I used to think about all sorts of things
about life and and and how things worked.
I became a trained biochemist and I was
doing a post-doc on the NIH campus.
I was sequencing genes. I realized very quickly
that you cannot do that without a computer.
So I started learning how to use a
computer, how to set up computers,
how to expand computers to deal
with bigger amounts of data.
And soon became the expert in the
lab on computational biology methods.
The research I'm doing now is about turning genes
on and off and in order to do that we
need to analyze very large data sets.
And to analyze large data sets, we use software
that we develop to process the
data on significant computers.
Our research is more designed around
what the natural process is in the cell.
Things in the nucleus are not flat. The
chromosomes fold into chromatin and the
chromatin itself folds into higher structures.
And all these are in some sort
of flux at all times. So when
they become used for up-regulation or
down-regulation to create more protein,
all of that is one big concert of events taking
place to create or suppress a different function.
Our work on the natural process of biology acts
as a foundation for clinicians, geneticists,
and physicians to try and understand
what happens in people that get sick.
You have to have an imagination. If you don't
have an imagination, it's hard to do science.
I think I'll always be this curious
and I'll turn it up again when my grandchildren can
be challenged with these questions.
The beauty of handing the curiousness over
to the next generation is very important.
But I'm looking forward to the time
that I can walk around a field and
explain to them things that they never
thought of and make them more curious.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]